well joining us now is general sir
richard sheriff the former deputy
supreme allied commander of nato thank
you very much indeed for being with us
uh just first of all your reaction to
these developments this
evening well i think we need to be
extremely worried this has been ramping
up for some time
uh and today's announcements are in a
sense setting the scene for what may
well follow which will be a russian
invasion of of ukraine
so you think it could be a broad
invasion of ukraine not
limited to
putting
you know his troops into the donbass
region as peacekeepers or something like
that
let's be clear if putin puts his troops
into
donetsk and lehansk and the donbass that
is an invasion of a sovereign nation
that is uh changing the boundaries of
europe by by force or continuing to
change the boundaries of europe by force
um there are clear options i mean there
are a number of options he could go for
uh the donbass
he could decide to attack in a sort of
blitzkrieg attack on kia on kiev
or he could bite off a chunk of
southeast southeast ukraine to give
himself a land corridor an axa land
corridor down to crimea
but any of those options is an invasion
any of those options will lead to
fighting on a scale and of an intensity
not seen in europe since 1945.
and how do you think nato should now
react and the west should now react to
what he has announced well nato needs to
man the ramparts frankly frankly
and i'd be absolutely determined to
demonstrate that it's ready to defend
nato territory at whatever cost whether
it's in the baltic states whether it's
romania bulgaria
or elsewhere and we in the uk need to
understand
that the defense of our country stops
not starts not on the the white cliffs
of dover the murray firth or east anglia
the east anglian coastline but it starts
in the forest
of of lithuania of estonia of of of
latvia
and elsewhere on eastern's on nato's
eastern border so nato needs to be
ramping up its reinforcement uh of
capability in uh in its eastern
territories in the air and in our sea
lines of communication with the east
but an invasion a broad scale
full invasion of ukraine doesn't bear
thinking about in terms of
of the chaos it will cause and the loss
in human life
it does not but we need to recognize
the full implications of what may be
about to unfold
maybe about to unfold do you think
that he would really do that is
he stands to
become an isolated leader a pariah state
with an economy that will be
severely damaged do you think he will
take that gamble
he also stands to to to generate a an
extraordinarily a massive problem for
russia if he invades ukraine because the
ukrainians will fight like
hell clearly we don't know what he will
do
but every step he takes
is taking him russia europe and the
world closer to the edge of a precipice
and the closer he gets for the precipice
the more difficult it is to ramp back
he is holding a gun to nato's head he is
demanding no less than the dismantling
of the alliance uh but that has been his
long-term aim there's nothing new here
there's been a this has been in the
playbook for putin
since at least 2014 and we have just
watched and let it happen